MARK MIRCHANDANI: Uh-oh.
I just got an email
that our app is down.
Apparently, the
database is hanging,
and we're losing transactions.
MATT DAY: If we set
up a circuit breaker,
the app can respond to the
error, rather than hanging.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But
then each of our services
has to implement its own
logic for circuit breaking?
MATT DAY: This is an
infrastructure problem.
Why don't we solve it
with Kubernetes and Istio?
Let me show you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So here's my website.
As you can see, it's a
one-stop shop for everything
you need to buy in
order to be the best
hipster that you can be.
It's built on Google
Kubernetes Engine,
with the optional
Istio add-on enabled.
One of the neat
things Istio gives
is visibility into
everything that's going on.
In this case, I'm going to
use the open source Kiali
console to show that.
As you can see, I have
two microservices--
my front end, which is
talking to Cloud Memorystore
for session caching,
and my product catalog,
which is talking to Cloud
SQL for product information,
pricing, and that kind of thing.
Istio has a concept of versions.
And I have two versions
of my product catalog--
the working version
and the broken version.
The broken version
simulates the kind
of issues I've seen in
the past, where service
takes too long to respond.
This could be due to a
stressed out database
with millions of transactions
waiting to be processed.
Perhaps there's infrastructure
issues or networking problems.
Whatever it is, it's things that
make my entire website fail.
I can tell you, if I
went to a website that
took 15 plus seconds to render
a web page every time I clicked
a link, I'd probably go to
one of their competitors.
And that's exactly what my
broken service simulates.
It takes a connection,
holds it for 15 seconds,
and eventually replies.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So even
if a service is down,
we can have our application
handle the error,
rather than just hanging?
MATT DAY: Right.
With Istio, you could enforce
a blackout, rather than
a brownout, when the
service is misbehaving.
In the past, you'd have had to
include all sorts of libraries
to do that.
And it can get
really complicated.
Let me show you how to do it.
So let's turn on
that broken version,
send some traffic to it,
and show how Istio can help.
One of the core concepts in
Istio is a virtual service.
A virtual service
defines where my traffic
is routed within the mesh.
So I'm going to say,
send 100% of my traffic
to the broken version
of my microservice.
If I apply that change and go
back to my app and refresh it,
you'll see Chrome is
hanging because my back end
service is hanging.
At this point, you've
lost me as a customer.
But worse, if this
was a payment service,
you may have even
lost a sales record.
I've seen all of this
and worse in the past
due to these kind of bugs.
So what can we do
to mitigate it?
In the past, we might have
used circuit breaker libraries.
The problem with this
approach is that they're
very language-specific.
So if one app is written
in Java and another in Go,
they'll have
different libraries,
and sharing state between
them is difficult.
Istio gives me a way to solve
this with circuit breaker
patterns.
There are two cool
things at play here.
The first is my
destination rule.
The destination rule
defines not only
the versions of my application,
but also characteristics
on how they receive traffic.
In this case, I'm
saying allow a maximum
of 200 pending requests.
But I could also put things
like TCP session information
and all kinds of
settings for my mesh
to understand what
this app can deal with
and what its tolerances are.
In this case, I can never have
more than 200 pending requests.
The 201st request will
simply see my app is down.
A blackout, not a brownout.
The second thing I can do
is modify my virtual service
to change the maximum
amount of time a request can
wait for my app to reply.
By default, this could
be virtually infinite.
But for some apps,
that's not appropriate.
In the case of my
catalog service,
I never want to wait for
more than one second.
If I apply this
change now, Istio,
with that maximum
of one second, will
intercept the call, which
is taking 15 seconds,
and say no, and instead
give me a 503 gateway
error to my app, which I
can deal with very easily,
and I can just show that
my catalog is offline.
The cool thing about
this is I've not
changed a single line of code.
And the very neat
thing is in my console,
I have visibility of
these broken requests.
I can see my service is down
without waiting for my users
to go to a competitor.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Great.
So now our application is able
to properly handle the errors.
MATT DAY: Right,
and you only need
to change a little
bit of config.
Didn't have to touch
any of your code.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Don't forget
to subscribe for more great
Google Cloud Platform content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]